جاء في مقال نشرته صحيفه الموند ان تمسك
القاده السياسيين في اسرائيل بانكار احقيه
الشعب الفلسطيني في الوجود والرغبه
الجامحه في مواصله الحرب الكارثيه على
قطاع غزه ربما يدفعان محكمه العدل الدوليه
الى الاقرار بمعقول قضيه الاباده الجماعيه
واتخاذ تدابير مؤقته استنادا الى الاحكام
القضائيه الاخيره المرتبطه بميانمار
واوكرانيا السترد جورنال نشرت تقريرا يقول
ان مضي اسرائيل قدما في خططها لبناء منطقه
عازله في غزه يهدد بصدع جديد في العلاقات
مع الولايات المتحده يضيف التقرير ان
المسؤولين الامريكيين يشعرون باحباط
متزايد بشان المشروع ويحذرون من انه يعزز
المخاوف لدى الفلسطينيين من احتلال
اسرائيل لاراضيهم ويصعب من مهمه اقناع
الحكومات العربيه بالمساعده في اعاده
اعمار القطاع
المدمر في في صحيفه الجارديان مقال خلص
الى ان اصرار نتنياهو على رفض حل الدولتين
الذي يتحدث عنه بايدن باستمرار يعكس شعورا
لدى نتنياهو بقدرته على الافلات من العقاب
نتنياهو ادرك من سلوك الاداره الامريكيه
وفق المقال ان تدفق المساعدات مستمر وكذلك
الدعم الدبلوماسي ويذكر المقال بقضيه
الصحفيه شيرين ابو عاقله قائلا ان البيت
الابيض لم يقف الى جانبها ضد
اسرائيل اثار تقرير في في صحيفه واشنطن
بوست قضيه منع اسرائيل الصحفيين الاجانب
من تغطيه الحرب في غزه مشيرا الى ان صحفيا
اسرائيليا اجاب عند سؤاله عن السبب بان
دخول مراسلين غربيين الى غزه سيسبب صداعا
لاسرائيل ويؤثر في الهاسب الاسرائيليه ثم
يلفت التقرير الى ان العالم تمكن رغم ذلك
من متابعه الاحداث المروعه في غزه بفضل
الصحفيين الغزيين الشجعان الذين بذلوا كل
ما بوسعهم لتوثيق الوقائع وكان ثمن ذلك
باهضا يعلق التقرير في صحيفتها ارتس مقال
يعتبر ان وصف نتنياهو لدور الوساطه
القطريه بالاشكال يجر سلوكه في زمن الحرب
الى مستوى منخفض جديد المقال انتقد بشده
ما سماها محاوله نتنياهو تحميل قطر
مسؤوليه ما يجب ان يتحمله هو وتحدث عن دور
مركزي وحيوي لقطر في قضيه تحرير الرهائن
من الواضح ان نتنياهو اراد من خلال
تسريبات تعطيل صفقه محتمله نتنياهو ذهب
هذه المره بعيدا باكاذيب به وهو بهذا يخلق
اعداء لشن حرب لا نهايه لها في الشرق
الاوسط